RESULTS?
>> Dana: WE HAVE THE REMAINING
RESULTS.
IF YOU COULD SHARE WITH US WHAT
WE KNOW?
>> Bret: 62%, YOU’RE SEEING
THIS ON THE SCREEN.
HERE THE PRECINCTS WERE IN.
A SLIGHT LEAD OF PETE BUTTIGIEG
OVER BERNIE SANDERS.
ELIZABETH WARREN IN THIRD AND
JOE BIDEN BACK AT UNDER 16% AND
FORTH.
AMY KLOBUCHAR AT 13% IN THESE
EARLY NUMBERS.
LET’S JUST BE SURE WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS 62% OF THE PRECINCTS.
THIS IS NOT THE WHOLE PICTURE
AND THIS COULD CHANGE AS WE GET
MORE OF NOT ONLY THE REAL VOTE
TOTAL BUT ALSO WHAT HER DECISION
DESK IS GOING TO LOOK AT GOING
IN WITH OUR VOTER ANALYSIS.
>> Martha: WE WANT TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THE COUNTIES AND GET A
FEEL FOR WHICH COUNTIES ARE
STILL OUT THERE AND WHERE THOSE
COUNTIES ARE AND HOW THEY MIGHT
IMPACT THE REMAINING MOVEMENT OF
THESE VOTES AS WE TAKE A LOOK.
BUT CLEARLY A GOOD NIGHT FOR
PETE BUTTIGIEG ANYWAY YOU
STRETCH IT.
EVEN IF HE ENDS UP IN SECOND
PLACE AND BERNIE SANDERS IN
FIRST PLACE, AND THAT COULD
HAPPEN AS THE REST OF THESE
NUMBERS COME IN.
HE CLAIMED VICTORY LAST NIGHT.
HE GOT A LOT OF HEAT FOR IT AND
IT DID FEEL LIKE HE JUMPED THE
GUN GIVEN THE SITUATION AS IT
WAS UNFOLDING BUT CLEARLY HE HAS
PERFORMED WELL HERE.
NO DOUBT, HE’S IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
AS HE’S MOVED ON TO CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: OF THE SANDERS
NUMBERS THEY PUT OUT TODAY SAY
HE IS GOING TO PULL THIS OUT IN
THE END AT ABOUT 30% OVER
PETE BUTTIGIEG AT 24%.
THEY ARE GOING BY THEIR PRECINCT
CAPTAINS AND THEIR INTERNAL VOTE
COUNT.
WE CAN’T CONFIRM THAT BUT
LOOKING AT THESE NUMBERS, AT
62%, YOU REALIZE HOW LUCKY
JOE BIDEN WAS LAST NIGHT TO GET
OUT OF THERE BECAUSE HE IS
FOURTH.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHO NOW HEADS
INTO NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE
BERNIE SANDERS IS RUNNING
STRONG.
>> Dana: MARTHA, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE VOTER TURNOUT WAS
CUSTOMER THAT WAS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS LAST NIGHT.
IF THE TURNOUT WAS MORE LIKE
2016 THAN IT WAS IN 2008 THAT
THAT DIDN’T SOUND TOO GOOD FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
DO WE KNOW A THING ABOUT THAT
FROM THESE NUMBERS?
>> Bret: THEY ARE STILL
STAYING WITH 2016 RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD NUMBERS FOR
DEMOCRATS OVER ALL.
MAY BE BETTER FOR MAYOR
PETE BUTTIGIEG THAN IT IS FOR
SANDERS.
SANDERS WOULD’VE BENEFITED FROM
THE 240, THE BARACK OBAMA YEAR
NUMBER.
240,000.
BUT IT LOOKS CLOSER TO 2016,
170,000.
>> Martha: IF THAT HOLDS WHEN
WE GET THE FULL LOOK AT THIS I
THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE BIG
STORY LINES HERE AS WELL.
IT BEGS THE QUESTION, IS THERE A
CANDIDATE WHO IS REALLY DRIVING
THIS RACE ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
AND EXCITING PEOPLE TO GET OUT
AND VOTE AND PARTICIPATE IN ALL
OF THIS?
THEY WERE REALLY EXPECTING
BLOWOUT NUMBERS, THAT THEY MIGHT
EVEN SURPASS THE NUMBER IN 2008
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHICH IS
ABOUT 240,000, SO THAT IS
SOMETHING TO WATCH FOR THE
CLOSELY AND WE WILL SEE IF IT
CHANGES AS WE GET THE REST OF
THESE NUMBERS.
>> Bret: ONE MORE THING, THE
AMY KLOBUCHAR CAMPAIGN THINKS
THERE NUMBERS SHOW THEM NECK AND
NECK WITH JOE BIDEN IN FOURTH
AND MAYBE EVEN OVERTAKING HIM.